hello everybody my name is markiplier it
is loud in here we are back in nightmare
mode haven't beaten you haven't gone to
you
I mean you minion being you so there's
no excuses about it it's time to go all
I gotta do is beat these Knight five
moments right these Knight five modes
and I'll be good to go I still think
they're gonna [ __ ] with me one day and
there's gonna be something here but oh
well there's nothing now so this is five
nights at Freddy's one five nights at
Freddy's 1 that means that it's probably
gonna be dickish sleep but I think it's
fine like I don't know how it could be
bad unless there's something new about
it that is bad so let's try it like us
to do is not die oh [ __ ] hey get the
[ __ ] outta here
what are you doing oh [ __ ] show what
static followed by scary demon noises
well that's a little weird you're
already walking so all I gotta do is
just check the doors and check the light
you're already coming out god damn it
like oh what the whoa whoa wow wow what
the [ __ ] whoa whoa what the [ __ ] was
that about holy [ __ ] oh god wait what
the [ __ ] god damn I'm Andy's these
fingies they're not being very fingy I'm
checking these two too much I know but
uh trying to be real gentle about it I
think that wet
stop doing that nonsense coming down
that's good
you'll be done now can you be done with
your tantrum oh stop
why what the [ __ ] I mean besides that if
that happens at the wrong time and
Foxy's come and running down that the
corridor oh [ __ ] whose daughter I do
here someone I think this is fine this
is fine
Wow Wow gosh [ __ ] every [ __ ] pundit
oh hi okay you're there are you gonna
stop there or what are you going right
by okay you're fine you're fine I just
gotta check you because if you pop up
it's gonna be grilled oh [ __ ] oh you're
closing that one you're still there yeah
I think what I gotta do is I gotta wait
for him to come out whoa [ __ ] okay
double double teaming oh hey hey whoa
hey okay is there someone there is there
something up stop holy [ __ ] um you're
not there anymore what the [ __ ] are you
there oh you're not laughs [ __ ] I am
gonna die cuz I'm gonna run out power
are you still there what what the [ __ ]
what is that about
are you still there Oh God go away oh
[ __ ]
I'm gonna run a power holy [ __ ] this is
tough but not that tough well I gotta
get solid steel balls and stop the
goddamn not miss brow right okay dad I
didn't like you [ __ ] down like why
why are you still here
no okay you haven't gone yet you're
still there for some [ __ ] reason I
don't know why oh my god okay I'm
power because I gotta keep this door
down for some [ __ ] reason oh my god
oh my god don't you dump it on me I
don't want to be dum de dum I'm nowhere
near I'm nowhere near time I am nowhere
near time and I am out of power
I guess I'm near time alright well [ __ ]
it okay but I had another hour to go
okay it's fine
kill me do it oh holy [ __ ] that's all I
hate that here we go come on I'm ready
for you take some lace okay number one
why did the right door never go away
ever don't don't don't you [ __ ] do it
alright so I'm gonna take it just a step
back just to breathe Oh [ __ ] let me
breathe okay alright so I'm guessing
that with that game mode the right doors
at a certain point it's gonna stay
closed so my only objective is to not
close it until as late as possible cuz
if that [ __ ] just gonna stay there
I'm not gonna waste power trying to like
check to make sure he's still there he
apparently is just gonna stay there so
once he's there he's there for good
do you understand what I'm talking about
here do you get what I'm saying once
he's there he's there for good why is my
hand over there it's over here I was
being sassy on the hip but you get what
I'm saying right okay let's do this
again all this is is trial and error I
don't think it's that bad I got to 5
a.m. which is pretty far and that was
with spastically waving my hands about
shut up don't need that you don't scare
me no mo because I've got the recipe for
victory my hands are being a little I
don't know why but in here the hands are
just being a little bit caddywhompus
ain't nothing turn that off get that off
these ain't nothing I don't need to
check the lights nearly as much as I'm
checking he's he's like between like a
doing
like a dream like a dream there he goes
check that get him to go down there
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
okay okay you're walking that's good
keep walking again stop there stop stop
god [ __ ] damn it for the love of poop
just stop okay none of that none of that
okay you're there but you're not in the
doorway yet so I can squeeze Scott
[ __ ] damnit okay all right well
that's interesting
you're not in the doorway yet so as soon
as you're in the door you're yeah you're
staying right by so I just got to watch
for you once you go this is how we're
gonna do this okay there we go that's
good okay you've moved yep there you are
okay so that door is just no go for ever
I guess I'm just guessing that's what it
is right that's just what it is
get a little [ __ ] but it's okay cuz
he didn't go away at all and I mean at
all
[ __ ] okay that was very close that
was way too close okay
god dammit that's a lot of power I'm
just watching this one from now on I
just watched this one when you move okay
there you are and I close that and yeah
it's a lot of power but with him not
yeah he's there so he stays there it's
just that's just the way it is
no 4 a.m. 22% addend asipi it's real
iffy I'm not a hundred percent sure
about this one but you know it is what
it is as conserving of energy as I
possibly can be know that none of that
okay he's just coming down and I yet
close about through enough power
it's gonna be tight it's gonna be real
close [ __ ] god damn it really right
then I could have made it
oh [ __ ] you a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] yeah be like that you're gonna be
like that huh you gonna be like that
you're gonna be like dad you're gonna be
like dad that was close that that might
have actually got it to be honest that
might have actually got it I don't need
to check the lights nearly as much as
I'm checking them every time I check a
light is for what the [ __ ] wait what
the [ __ ] my buttons my buttons happen
hello hello my buttons okay
well loosen up my buttons bad somebody
fix my whoa okay all right well you know
this will be the first buttonless run
all right well no buttons for me cameras
are for nerds I just gotta get foxy
reaction times but that's about it
nobody sorry we don't need buttons here
buttons are for nerds damn it my fingers
are so sticky in this level why thingies
behave yourselves are you coming down
that way okay so I got people on both
sides
stop no not today so far so good
weirdly enough okay you go by there
that's fine fair's fair fair [ __ ] I see
you I thought you already won by I could
have sworn there I know you're there I
see you okay see you whoa okay all right
let's not do that
oh you're there okay so that's just
bizarre
but did you do
okay a little bit longer little bit
longer okay so that's this close now so
all I gotta do is check this side and I
don't even need to check it I just need
to be ready on the door is all this is
my life now
for I am 40 percent that's pretty good
I'd say [ __ ] sticky fingers oh [ __ ]
where did you come from
[ __ ] got ya oh [ __ ] that that takes huge
hits of power huge hits that does that
really drains my power okay
I forgot that foxy actually hit power
down Bonnie's there somewhere God [ __ ]
sticky fingers I hate that okay 5 a.m.
we're close God stop being stupid
where are you Bonnie are you oh you
going back oh so you didn't even uh
interesting okay I'll take that
all right powers running out and come on
come on give me a give me give me give
me give me give me give me give me give
me give me give me come on wait whoa
whoa whoa yes yes yes yes
hahahahaha
you suck I win all right my berries in
chocolate I love berries I love
chocolate and I love berry
so this will be good for me my nose do
it boo boo incus okay good good good
good good good good good
whew that was a bit more trying than I
thought but not as bad as like a twenty
mode I appreciate that
ease of that I appreciate the ease of
that I appreciate the ease of - so that
is all the time I have right now I gotta
get going we're still film
this amazing project over here wherever
the hell I am so I got to get back to
business but thank you everybody so much
for watching hope you enjoyed that and I
will try to get to more than one of the
night fives in the next episode it's
just I have a limited amount of time
right now so thank you everybody so much
and as always I will see you
[Music]